first of all you look fantastic thank
you I just threw myself to get there
hello clothes gloves have been my
official like quarantine and zoom chimes
accessory yeah
disclosure is such an important
documentary that everyone should watch
the ways in which trans people have been
represented have suggested that we're
mentally ill that we don't exist and yet
here we are and we've always been here
so where does the idea come from
disclosure it's a documentary film that
looks at a history of transgender
representation on screen yeah really in
Hollywood and how those representations
influence the way people think about
trans people and how we think about
ourselves there are lots of ugly things
about our history but I think we have to
know the review 30 different trans folks
everyone on camera strands and how
brilliant and beautiful and intelligent
and insightful they are and the contrast
between the real live trans people and
some of the representations that we see
on screen it's so stark to see the
difference between the beautiful
humanity of the people we interview and
then the often objectified
sensationalized inhumane images that
permeate a history of trans
representation on screen
I've decided so many times they can't
even count on camera I have been a
prostitute prostitute one prostitute
call girl okay oftentimes you know in TV
or in film we've seen violence against
transgender women which is completely
disgusting but it can be the reality at
times for what people are going through
um where do you stand with that being
seen on screen still in 2020 there's a
history of how we've been represented
and for me it's really important that we
don't sort of erase these films and
these TV shows and that we don't cancel
people that we learn from the history
right so I'm not an advocate of like
pulling things from from the shelves and
never showing them again I think we need
to know the history to understand and
learn and grow from it in terms of where
we are now there unfortunately violence
against trans people is a reality that
of our lives I think almost every day
open my phone and see another trans
person has been beaten or murdered and I
I'm just really tired of saying that
honestly and in real life and I think
yes we need our film and our television
to reflect reality but then also I think
we can also have use art to show what
was possible what is possible how do we
begin to imagine a different a different
world and our art can also do that